he sent you here to get me
because the crisis is here I will be running
home
Batwoman there is no more time the
multiverse is in great danger I'm sorry
the what
I'm fighting to make things right
Who are you people we need your help
stopping this antimatter wave you just
told me my world is over and you need my
help
no one else has to die
come with me I need your help to avert a
crisis that threatens the entire
multiverse welcome to the joy zone
there's a wave of antimatter destroying
everything in its path until it'll
obliterates all reality we can beat
this together
suit up for the biggest crossover ever
we've got your backs
the CW's crossover event begins Sunday
December 8th presented by boost mobile
should have told me what was going to
happen on earth-2
John was there he could have been
the destruction of that earth was a
necessary sacrifice what about Laurel
Lance her friends her family countless more
like them will perish if we do
not ensure that Oliver Queen is
prepared for what is coming were you
successful yes
I have dr. Wong
let us go see welcome back everyone big
surprise they dropped a bunch of new
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer videos
so we'll break it all down there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs there's a
bunch of other scenes that aren't in
these trailers that I'll breakdown and
obviously we have that scene with lilah
confirming that she is the harbinger
character that's been working with the
monitor she's probably been Harbinger at
this whole time we're doing a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite moment from the
trailers on the video they brought back
so much stuff just in this footage and
it's only a fraction of the stuff that's
happening during the crossover there's
obviously going to be Easter eggs for every possible thing TV show movie comic book
that you could possibly imagine
but I'll start at the beginning of the
footage and just go through shot by shot
so you start with the flash asking lilah
who's gone full Harbinger if the monitor
has sent her to get him because it's
time for crisis on Infinite Earths to
start is it time then they use the logo
transitions with the antimatter wave
just letting you know that everything is
being wiped from existence there's a
reference to the original marketing for
a comic book crisis worlds will live
worlds will die in the DC Universe will
never be the same
they've already wiped earth to off the
map and a couple others so far
obviously they're going to get rid of a
whole bunch of others too but they
actually used that line of dialogue from
the comics in last year's crossover with
a psycho pirate character so I'm
wondering if he's going to come back in
cameo again during this in some way
because psycho-pirate was a big crisis
comic-book character there's a lot of
battle scenes with them fighting some
unseen force running it's something off
of screen we do actually see them later
in the trailer fighting the actual
anti-monitor in a giant rock quarry they
just break that scene up throughout the
trailer a bunch of different times this
is a scene of what seems like Barry in a
regular clothes running on the cosmic
treadmill at STAR Labs hopefully
there'll be some references to the
actual comic book cosmic treadmill
because the one at STAR Labs is just a
super version of a treadmill it's not
the actual cosmic treadmill
this is Barry inside what seems like one
of the labs on supergirls earth 38 most
of the footage seems like it's from a
couple different episodes like them
fighting the anti-monitor probably from
later in the crossover but most of the
rest of this footage seems like it's
from the first episode of the crossover
because they're getting the call to
action from Lyla she's going around
grabbing everybody and a lot of the
other characters seem like they're
meeting other care
for the first time berry references
coming home to you that's the original
song that he's saying during season 3
Supergirl also sang that song at their
wedding ceremony during the crossover a
couple years ago there's another scene
of 90s flash Barry Allen's symbol broken
on the cosmic treadmill implying that
he's either died or somehow his costume
just got ripped to shreds hopefully they
do not end him off then lyla goes to
pick up batwoman she's on the same
earth as the flash and arrow so it's not
like she's hopping to another reality
she just in Gotham City this kind of
seems like it's a version of their Wayne
Manor I have not been watching that show
so I'm not totally sure whether or not
they're going to bring that version of
Batman into the crossover the one Batman
that we know we're getting is the Kevin
Conroy Batman from Batman the Animated
Series he's kind of playing the older
80-something Batman from Batman Beyond
then you have the flash Cisco in pariah
going to pick up black lightning on his
earth and him just completely freaking
out what are you doing here wait you
need my help
this is one of the only times that you
see which earth they're on when they
flash this map of the multiverse it says
earth 73 that's actually a big reference
to 1973
the year that the Superfriends team-up
TV show was created and they're kind of
doing a version of Super Friends with
them all teaming up for the crossover
sort of a TV version of Justice League
they've also referenced Super Friends in
the pastor and crossovers to the Hall of
Justice is that building on the flash TV
show we just haven't gone there in a
couple of years then you see Black
Lightning interacting with heatwave and
frost at STAR Labs
this scene of Lyla freaking out on a
hospital bed seems like it's maybe when
she's starting to go full Harbinger from
the comics love this scene of Black
Lightning interacting with 90s flash
Barry Allen I'm so happy they're
bringing him back then Black Lightning
just lighting something up with his
powers Lyla goes to pick up the legends
who seem like they're just chilling out
in a sports bar over beers Ray Palmer
suiting up you see him in battle with
everyone else there's a bunch of Ray
Palmer all over this early footage but
remember he's also playing Kingdom Come
Superman during this we see heatwave and
frost together flash rogues
team-up moment it's been forever since
heat wave has been on the flash or
inside STAR Labs we get that funny
one-liner from Sara welcome to the funs
though then this is them a bum-rushing
the anti-monitor you can see his armor
looks a little bit different from the
monitors armor it's almost exactly like
comic book anti
monitor without the crazy helmet that he
wears on top but this is what his face
looks like when he's not wearing that
helmet remember we also got that footage
of this same quarry with a version of
the monitor with no facial hair or
mutton chops so I'm starting to wonder
if he's somehow connected to the
anti-monitor then in the last couple of
scenes this is actually pretty
interesting you see a version of
Superman's cape torn and hung up like a
flag waving in the wind just like during
the death of Superman after he had been
ended by doomsday but which version of
Superman's cape is it or Supergirl so
the thing is it's not Supergirl or earth
38 Superman's cape their capes look like
this in it's not Smallville Superman Tom
Wellings cape his cape looks like this
we know Brandon Roth is playing an older
version of Christopher Reeve Superman
just because of the way the continuity
of Superman Returns works and his cape
is a little bit different from that
movie but this is Christopher Reeves
cape this is his cape during that movie
he's also playing Kingdom Come superman
wearing a version of that comic book
costume and this is what that cape looks
like so either this happens to be a
totally different version of Superman
that they wind up ending an
alternate earth and it's a big Easter
Egg for another version or issues from
an earlier battle but let me know in the
comments if you can spot which version
of Superman's cape this is from which TV
show which movie which comic book
reference because none of the capes I
can think of look exactly like this but
heads up they probably will end at
least one version of Superman during the
crossover but obviously because earth 38
Superman is getting his own TV show next year it's definitely not going to be him
then they have a team meeting on
supergirls earth heartfelt talk with
Superman and then some more that big
battle scene in the quarry with the
anti-monitor
the other new scenes that they reveal
but aren't in this trailer are
confirmation on baby John Kent Superboy
he'll be featured more on that Superman
TV show next year team Supergirl then
Lina Luthor and Alex helping out so Lina
in addition to Lex Luthor will
participate in at least the first
episode of the crossover Batwoman
Superman is Supergirl then all of the
actors from the first episode of the
crossover together just mugging for
camera this is them behind the scenes
Oliver the legends Mia Smoak the flash
Martian Manhunter the Supergirl
characters Ray Palmer and bat woman then
Oliver having a heart-to-heart chat with
earth thirty eight Superman Oliver and
Mia then bat woman Superman Ray Palmer
the
right in the middle of a fight but
what's going to happen is is because all
the footage is starting to drop now
there'll be a much bigger trailer that
will probably drop sometime next week
because that's when all the shows come
back they were on break this week I know
a lot of you are still wondering what's
the deal with Tom Wellings Smallville
Superman what's he going to be doing
which side of the crossover he is going
to be in yes there was a convention a
little while ago where someone implied
that Tom Welling said that he was only
in a couple scenes for the crossover it
was going to be like a really huge role but
he would be doing something really cool
so just be sure to couch your
expectations in terms of how they use
that Tom Welling Superman character
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening
they just announced five brand new
Marvel phase 5 mystery movies I'm doing
a new Holt video I'll talk about those
movies when I post that sometime in the
next couple of days while you wait for
everything click here for my last big
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer video
and click here for my brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2 video thank you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!